Aspiration in Mexico.
New images
into CNN of a trailer
packed with more
than 129 migrants, mostly from Guatemala,
discovered in southern Mexico.
Temperatures there topped 110 degrees
this week.
And among those
making that dangerous journey.
19 children,
they were traveling
without their parents.
And they are just part
a small, small part
of the migrant surge in Mexico.
Where many are waiting to cross
into the United States.
And David Culver has this special report
that you will see first here OUTFRONT
on the Texas-Mexico border.
U.S.
law enforcement patrol
the tranquil waters of the Rio Grande
The flow of migrants here
slowing to a trickle
since title
42 ended in May on sidewalks in El Paso
that last month were covered
with migrants.
Today, only a handful camped out,
but travel
more than 500 miles south
into places like Mexico. City.
And the numbers are rapidly rising.
Overwhelming for the Catholic nuns
who run this shelter.
Sister Maria Silva says at night
every aspect of the shelter
floor is normal
and not the end of the year.
Inside and outside
covered with the thin mattresses
you see stacked around us in La Frontera,
Del said.
Wow.
The Mexico City,
which is very far from the border,
as she sees it,
has now become a border town.
But in the center of Mexico,
the migrants here spend their mornings
trying to get an appointment
with a US
asylum officer using the CBP one app.
Getting a confirmed date.
That's entirely impossible for some.
You can tell it's it's crushing her.
And I said to
What are you guys going to do?
And they said,
Just wait, wait for the date.
Maria Jose
Camacho and her husband and their lawyers
from Venezuela
arrived two weeks ago in Mexico
with their four year
old daughter
living here for the past several days.
I don't want to go wanting to leave.
They feel like after ten or 42 expired,
that it's
now much more difficult to try to cross.
Title 42,
the pandemic era immigration policy
allowed U.S.
officials to immediately
expel migrants who crossed illegally
without processing their claim
for asylum.
Those same migrants would often
try and try again until they got in.
Now, Title eight back in full effect.
Sure, it gives migrants
the right to claim asylum
but those who failed to qualify
risk being banned from entering the U.S.
for at least five years.
The result?
Migrants flooding into Mexico,
where they then
wait to figure out
how they can get into the U.S.
And you can see encampments have already
taken up most of this
little square here.
You can see along
the street
you've got an art gallery,
a nice restaurant.
But then just turn the corner here
and look down the sidewalk.
You can see tents
and families
who have been set up for days and weeks
with nowhere else to go.
At this point,
we drive an hour outside Mexico City
where a government run
shelter is set up to handle the overflow.
Officials tell us most here from Haiti,
makeshift medical stations,
this little girl
complaining of a sore throat.
Her dad says she's not wanted to eat in
five days.
They pass the time doing chores
and playing sports.
Their cell phones
sit in a web of chargers.
Battery power
fuels their chances of getting an online
CBP appointment.
Eventually they move on.
So you can see these folks here
are going to be boarding the bus.
They're going to go meet
with Mexican authorities
and get paperwork
that allows them asylum in Mexico.
Basically,
they're trying to buy more time
so as to then continue on their journey
to get closer to the U.S.
border,
eventually get an appointment with a U.S.
asylum officer.
And they hope to enter the U.S.
legally since title 42 expired.
Migrant crossings are down for now.
At least.
We visited Eagle Pass, Texas.
Main Street, quiet.
But Texas Congressman Tony Gonzalez warns
what we saw
building up in Mexico
will push north here.
So it's almost calm.
I say calm.
There's 800
apprehensions a day
just in the Del Rio sector.
On the other side of the Mexico
side, it's just building up. Building up.
The cartel will adapt
and then that will be
the next thing that they send over.
U.S.
border officials warn as more migrants
either fail to qualify for asylum
or grow frustrated waiting,
they're turning to cartel
controlled smugglers to get across.
The congressman
proposing a bipartisan approach
to counter that.
So I'm of the mindset,
stop sending them down that route.
Send them another route.
Work visas make sense to me.
Remove the politics in it.
Remove the
you have access to vote
or have access
to social services and say, hey,
do you want to have a job?
We have a job for you.
Link up the two.
Go back in Mexico City,
we find Maria, Jose and her
and their daughter
walking a busy commercial street
carrying a sign and candies
were a Venezuelan migrant family.
And we're asking for your support.
They tell me they're out here
3 hours twice a day.
I said, Okay, get busy.
So
she was a nurse in Venezuela.
And so doing this, resorting
to having to sell things,
it's different, as she points out.
But she'd rather do this
than just ask for money.
What's really concerning
in all of this,
Erin, is
you have
those Mexican cartel
backed smugglers who see all of this,
this buildup of migrants
as an opportunity
potential business for them.
Now, we know they've trafficked
human beings
through trunks of cars, through
truck trailers.
Now, according to U.S.
officials,
they've seen recent cases of migrants
being smuggled over the Pacific Ocean
and in many cases swimming
through the Pacific Ocean at night.
Just to get to the U.S.
shows you
how increasingly desperate
and treacherous these journeys are.
Yeah, the perfect words.
All right.
Thank you very much
for sharing all of that with us. David.